[Music]
ready one
two three
hey it's justine and today i am gonna
unbox
something really mad
we gotta get some tools now normally
i would unbox this with a small knife
probably one of these will do
so inside of here is an xbox
that's all i'm going to tell you right
now unless you read the title
[Music]
i don't know if i'm doing a very good
job or not
i switched knives because i thought
maybe this might be better
i thought that we did a good job already
but clearly there's a whole other layer
i'm just holding this knife now for
protection i think
oh my gosh there's master chief master
chief is larger than life
this is a life well this is more than a
life-size
xbox i wonder if this is the first
unboxing could be
this is so cool
[Music]
jenna just pulls the emergency cable off
of my garage door
oh no
[Music]
wow i'm still not actually sure what's
even in here so this is what the xbox
series x packaging will look like
granted i
don't think it's gonna be this big but
this looks like the retail box
right here one terabyte 4k
120. this is so
massive this is actually larger i think
than my first apartment in los angeles
jenna can attest to that it's true
look ak hdr i guess let's
let's go inside roll the dramatic music
now
guys it's happening it's half oh my gosh
oh my gosh oh my gosh
we're not done yet my gosh jenna put
your head in here
put your head in here oh my gosh
it's actually it looks exactly like the
freaking xbox
[Music]
they made the meme a thing
how do we get you out of here okay jen
this says we need two people for
deployment of ramp
yes i am one you are two that's the math
yep
uh okay so be careful
oh my okay all right okay
okay i mean i guess we just yeah now
what do we do you have to
put the rape down okay what are you
doing i don't know get out of the way
there you go see ram ready one two three
no look at this oh my gosh
what in the what this is so insane
i am i can't believe it is this a trick
are you guys going to close me up and
then me off somewhere we can't the
rhymes now
ah i can't wait to put all my yearbook
mates in here
just pull on it okay oh gosh
it's moving it's moving it's moving
jenna what did you think you were doing
today
not this never know does this fridge
have wheels
oh well and i think so gliding very
welcome to your new home
[Music]
the huge box is gone the fridge is now
officially here in the garage
next to baby ty well this is actual size
i haven't even opened it up yet i need
to put my yerba in there
oh this is like a very very nice
refrigerator like this is
a really nice fridge this is like an
actual refrigerator
oh wow
should i plug it in the back is also a
replica of the
tiny actual i keep calling it a tiny
xbox series x
but it's the actual size xbox series x
this is where the expansion card goes
we've got our hdmi
wow let's open this up whoa
custom that's custom this whole thing is
custom
can you imagine somebody just calling
someone
and being like hey can you can you do
this
[Music]
it freaking lights up
oh my god it is
i have goose bumps right now okay they
may have won't know they're there
they're there i promise you
but i just got chills when i opened this
up
okay let's do this okay let's do it
again you put that in there
here we go
how do they get a freaking custom sound
in this refrigerator
where's that coming from right here
right there there's a custom speaker
this is
so awesome
i can't believe this this is so crazy i
i am like speechless
the green is a lovely touch it's such a
lovely thought this is a nicer
refrigerator than i have in my house
right now
but this will not fit inside of my house
[Applause]
hello and welcome to my refrigerator
goodbye
a little touch of wi-fi here a little
touch of wi-fi there
[Music]
this is one of three refrigerators
that were made so xbox thank you guys so
much for sending me this this is so
amazing they're actually going to be
doing a twitter sweepstakes to give away
the third one
i have one and snoop dogg has one and
one of you guys might win one as well
make sure you guys check out xbox on
twitter for all of the information and i
look forward
to gaming season because it is just
about here
so i gotta fill this up with snacks
snacks
snacks snacks